-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
During the first ballot in
today's House speakership vote,
Ohio congressman Jim Jordan
fell short of the 217 votes
necessary to become speaker.
But Republicans are determined
to keep trying
until they finally get it wrong.
[ Laughter ]
During the first ballot in
today's House speakership vote,
several Republicans voted
for former New York
congressman Lee Zeldin,
which means they are
running out of options,
even alphabetically.
[ Laughter ]
"What about Ziggy Zyzax?
He's -- He's strong
on the border, right?"
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
over the weekend
announced that about
200 Floridians
were evacuated from Israel
and landed in Tampa,
marking the first time
in recorded history
that anyone was happy
to land in Tampa.
[ Laughter ]
"Well, maybe we'll
meet Tom Brady.
What?
Retired?"
In a post today on Truth Social,
former president Trump said
that Ohio congressman Jim Jordan
will be a great House speaker
and added that he had
his "complete and total
endorsement."
"Good luck with that,"
said David Perdue, Kari Lake,
Doug Mastriano,
Herschel Walker, Dr. Oz,
and that kid he forced
to mow his lawn.
[ Laughter, applause ]
It's a long list.
Justice Amy Coney Barrett
said in an interview yesterday
that the Supreme Court
should adopt an ethics code
and added, "All nine justices
are very committed
to the highest standards
of ethical conduct."
And when he read that interview,
Clarence Thomas laughed so hard,
he almost fell off
a billionaire's yacht.
[ Laughter ]
The drug manufacturer
Novo Nordisk announced yesterday
that it has acquired
a new hypertension drug
for $1.3 billion,
but they quickly
made that money back
after selling
five vials of insulin.
[ Audience groans ]
I guess my question is, where
did we think the laugh was?
[ Laughter ]
Like, as I'm saying it,
I'm like,
"Wait, this might not work."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, well...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Got something pretty cool,
though,
'cause you had to
suffer through that.
Everybody look under your seat.
Vial of insulin.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
baby boomers said
their top source for new slang
is younger family members.
Said your grandma,
"I crashed my whip
into the post office again."
[ Laughter ]
According to the same survey,
the most popular new slang word
used in Florida is "sus."
Well, yeah.
Have you ever been there?
I'm surprised it's not also
the most popular baby name.
"Yeah, we're calling him Sus.
We don't --
Doesn't look like either of us."
[ Laughter ]
Walmart has announced it will
offer the limited-edition
Van Leeuwen Kraft
Macaroni & Cheese ice cream.
It's a great way to make sure
your death is ruled a suicide.
[ Laughter ]
And finally --
You know would be good
with that?
Little vial of something.
Not going to say what.
And finally, Coca-Cola
and the makers of Absolut Vodka
announced yesterday
they're planning to release
a new ready-to-drink
vodka-Sprite cocktail,
because if you're mixing
vodka and Sprite,
you're ready to drink.
Yeah, I don't know, just two
liquids, one of them alcohol.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.